österreich kein wofür land voller
schlechter nachrichten anti corona demos
laufen aus dem ruder das größte lkw werk
des landes steht vor dem aus
intensivstationen verzeichnen
höchststände
die beliebtheit des kanzlers ist auf
einem allzeittief auch wegen peinlicher
einblicke in den maschinenraum der macht
dabei raum zu bastian kurz einen
pressetermin an ohne news aber mit
worten und bildern der hoffnung ganz
konkret geht es uns um das ziel bis in
einem jahr 500.000 menschen wieder in
beschäftigung zu bringen ein typischer
kurz sei das meint barbara toth die
österreichs wunderkind so ihr buch titel
seit jahren beobachtet folgt zu diesem
motto wenn ihr nicht gefällt worüber die
anderen sprechen dann ändert doch ganz
einfach das thema und die
österreichische medienlandschaft
funktioniert soweit so schlecht dass
dann alle auf das neue thema dass
sebastian kurz setzt aufspringen message
control nennen sie das und kurz
beherrschtes zur perfektion so wurde er
zum politstar zum gegenmodell der
europäischen konservativen
jüngster außenminister jüngster kanzler
europas brückenbauer nach rechts
hardliner der migrationspolitik
manchen deutschen politikern ist der
über vorbild anderen er nicht kurz
begeistert wähler mit frischen stil und
dem versprechen anders zu sein
keine politik keine
hinterzimmer-absprachen ich habe mich
bewusst gegen das weiterwursteln
entschieden und wir haben uns alle
gemeinsam bewusst für echte
veränderungen zu
der erfolg des systems kurz so erklärte
klaus knittelfelder beruhe auf einem
eingeschworenen kreis der 100 prozentig
auf den kanzler ausgerichtet sein
doch gegen enge vertraute den
finanzminister und den chef der
mächtigen staat heutigen övag wird nun
ermittelt wegen korruption oder
postenschacher so hat über chef schmidt
die ausschreibung für seinen lukrativen
chefposten selbst verfassen dürfen
entscheidend war nicht qualifikation
oder ausgewogenheit sondern zur familie
zu gehören zeigen die liegt der
kurznachrichten
schmidt schreibt an einen freund es
haben sich zwei top leute aus
deutschland beworben was wollen denn
diese piefkes in höhe und in anderen
zusammenhängen schreibt jemand an ihn
mir gehen die war so am nerv scheiß
quote kurz hat wohl bei der chefposten
besetzung das letzte wort er schreibt
dann schmidt kriegst du alles was du
willst
der antwortet ich bin so glücklich ich
liebe mein kanzler das system kurz wird
zum problem
es ist im endeffekt das verheerende für
für seine erzählung des neuen
politikstils tanner den informieren
versprochen hat oder genau dieser
zählung diese dieses versprechen
schweren schaden nimmt
die erzählung von der anderen politik
hatte schon einmal gelitten weil sich
kurz erster rechtspopulistische
koalitionspartner im gebiet aviso
bestechlich zeit für die nächste
koalition setzte kurz hohe maßstäbe und
darüber hinaus ist natürlich auch die
frage wer hat ja das moralische
potenzial eine regierung zu führen und
mit wem kann man stabil auch regieren
mit den grünen lautet die antwort und es
wird ein europaweiter pr erfolg für kurz
die koalition der gegensätze gilt als
wagnis
sie gelingt mit einem trick
migrationspolitik wird zum koalitions
freien raum erklärt kurz partei macht
sie die grünen müssen tatenlos zuschauen
definiert kurzfristig immer die grüne
partei weil sie sich nicht durchsetzen
können gegen die fdp die an zentrale
politik botschaft eigentlich das
migrations thema ist beziehungsweise
keinen millimeter von der harten linie
abzurücken
daher kommt ihr politischer erfolg das
und die pandemie zermürben das schwarz
grüne projekt und besonders den grünen
gesundheitsminister dienstag tritt
zurück
und bei der dritten welle haben wir
gemerkt dass die interessenskonflikte ja
immer stärker zugenommen haben ich habe
es eben einfach gesagt ich habe mich das
sehr oft habe sie alleine gefühlt
alleingelassen vom kanzler meint die
journalisten tot denn chefsache die
pandemie nur wenn es gutes zu verkünden
da aber sebastian kurz hat dieses spiel
ich bin da wenn es gut läuft und wenn es
dann mal kompliziert wird lasse ich das
wieder den gesundheitsminister machen
bis zur perfektion hin betreten zu
beginn der krise tritt kurz noch häufig
auf lobt sich kritisiert brüssel und
vergleicht sich immer wieder mit
deutschland meist zu österreichs vorteil
zuletzt anfang abbrechen wir haben von
mittlerweile über acht wochen öffnungs
schritte gesetzt wir haben den handel
die schulen die körper
dienstleister geöffnet während andere
länder wie zum beispiel auch unser
nachbarland deutschland im lockdown
geblieben sind
doch da ist ost österreich schon im
erneuten lockt die zahl der infektionen
und intensivpatienten höher als in
deutschland
scheinheilig sei kurz heißt es nun in
vielen eu-hauptstädten auch weil er die
eu attackiert lautstark für
osteuropäische nachbarn mehr impfstoff
fördert selbst für sie aber nichts
abgeben will so entzaubert sich kurz
hier sebastian kurz war so das
wunderkind der europäischen
konservativen und und jetzt hat man das
gefühl es eigentlich zum schmuddelkind
geworden was die phantasie
das war einmal chat protokollen und
koalitions krisen zum trotz ist der hier
zwar noch konkurrenzlos aber er hat den
jung star status verloren ist
geschrumpft auf umfrage mittelmaß ob ihm
das gefällt darf bezweifelt werden